Marvel has a lot of villains in its cinematic
universe, but which ones stand above the rest
when it comes to menacing Earth's Mightiest
Heroes?
To answer that increasingly complicated question,
we've watched every MCU movie and ranked all
of their many bad guys, from Batroc and Surtur
to Whiplash and Thanos, and everyone in between.
This list only focuses on tried-and-true villains,
so you won't find reformed heroes like Scarlet
Witch, Quicksilver, Nebula, or the Winter
Soldier.
We're talking 100 percent baddies through
and through.
So where does your favorite villain rank?
Here's our spoiler-filled take on every MCU
villain, ranked from worst to best.
Kurse
In The Dark World, Kurse leads a prison riot,
helps Malekith sack Asgard, and actually kills
Thor's mother, Frigga.
He also leads the battle against Thor in the
film's climax, beating the Thunder God senseless
with his brute strength.
Despite all that, Kurse is still little more
than a forgettable monster with no personality.
He's the ultimate mini-boss, and is in the
basement on this list's rankings.
Laufey
Laufey is a powerful force in Thor's corner
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe, but we never
really see much of him in action.
King of the Frost Giants and biological father
to Loki, he has super-strength and ice powers,
but he's still no match for the sneakiness
of his own son.
Loki manipulates events to get Laufey to attack
Asgard in Thor, but just as Laufey is about
to kill Odin, Loki takes out Laufey instead,
simultaneously killing the Frost Giant king
and making himself look like a hero.
Certainly an unceremonious end.
Brandt and Savin
Aldrich Killian turned out to be the A-list
bad guy in Iron Man 3, with Brandt and Savin
shaping up as little more than B-list versions
with the same powers.
Both are given their super-heating and healing
powers by the Extremis virus, and they both
attack Tony Stark throughout the film, but
neither is a match for Iron Man, even when
he doesn't have his suit.
Lame.
The Scorpion
He's a pretty big deal in the comics, but
in Spider-Man: Homecoming, not so much.
The Scorpion's most notable actions are complete
failures, first when an arms deal is interrupted
by Spider-Man, and then later when he tries
to get the Sinister Six going in prison before
being shut down by the Vulture.
Basically, he's just there to make Adrian
Toomes look cooler by comparison.
And when you're not as cool as the Vulture,
it's safe to say you screwed up pretty bad
somewhere along the way.
Batroc the Leaper
It's easy to forget, but yes, Batroc the Leaper
is part of the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
We meet the French mercenary during the action
sequence that opens The Winter Soldier, during
the hijacking of the ship, the Lemurian Star.
We get a breathless fight scene between the
two, with Cap accepting Batroc's challenge
for a hand to hand fight without his shield.
Batroc holds his own, though Cap eventually
knocks him out.
But hey, at least he's a little cooler than
this version.
The Shockers
Spider-Man: Homecoming gave us not just one,
but two Shockers.
We first meet Jackson Brice wielding a Shocker
gauntlet.
But after the Vulture kills him, the weapon's
passed to Herman Schultz.
Schultz looks to be our "main" Shocker in
the MCU, and he gets one epic fight against
Spidey before being sidelined.
Shocker jumps Peter as he leaves the school
dance attempting to follow the Vulture, and
sends him flying through a school bus, and
he loses his web-shooters, too.
So why does Shocker rank so low?
Because it wasn't even Spidey who took him
out, it was Pete's pal Ned, who grabs the
web-shooter and hits Shocker, distracting
him long enough for Spidey to web him to a
school bus.
Shocking.
Baron Von Strucker
Strucker led the experiments on Loki's scepter
that created Quicksilver and the Scarlet Witch,
so he's definitely important.
But all anyone really remembers about him
is his immediate surrender to the Avengers
during the opening of Age of Ultron.
"No surrender!"
"I am going to surrender."
In the end, Strucker was just another upper-level
Hydra goon.
Cut off his head, and no one really noticed.
The Destroyer
When the Destroyer shows up in Thor, it makes
full use of every moment.
The Destroyer's giant, powerful arms and legs
can crush or stomp just about any opponent,
and if they don't kill you, its laser blasts
probably will.
We saw the Destroyer kill a few Frost Giants,
then lay waste to a small town in New Mexico
when Loki sent it to Earth hunting Thor.
Still, it was no match for Thor when the God
of Thunder regained his power and overcharged
the Destroyer, ending the attack.
Justin Hammer
Credit Sam Rockwell's unending charisma for
Iron Man 2's Justin Hammer not showing up
at the very bottom of this list, or even further
down, if we could find a way to put him there.
As far as credible villains are concerned,
Justin Hammer is an absolute joke, he runs
an arms manufacturer that's a rival to Stark
Industries, except literally everything Hammer
builds falls apart.
The first version of the War Machine armor
is basically a bare-bones Iron Man suit outfitted
with a ton of Hammer weapons, which works
about as well as duct taping accessories to
a car.
To summarize: Sam Rockwell is great.
Justin Hammer still kinda sucks, though.
General Ross
In The Incredible Hulk, General Thaddeus "Thunderbolt"
Ross spends the entire film chasing Banner,
failing to kill him a few times along the
way.
For much of the film, he's a relatively one-dimensional
"Military Bad Guy."
Interestingly, however, Ross is one of the
few characters from The Incredible Hulk to
resurface later in the MCU.
He became the U.S. Secretary of State in Captain
America: Civil War, pushing for the adoption
of the Sokovia Accords, and even made a cameo
in Avengers: Infinity War, setting him up
for even badder bad guy stuff in films to
come.
Abomination
In an effort to capture the Hulk after Banner's
alter ego punches him through a tree, former
soldier Emil Blonsky hits himself with an
experimental version of the same gamma McGuffin
… except it doesn't turn him into another
Hulk.
Instead, he becomes the Abomination, a monstrous,
one-note creature that looks like a rotting
troll.
Yawn.
He lived through the end of The Incredible
Hulk and is apparently in a jail cell somewhere,
and the fact that Marvel hasn't really brought
him back since then tells you everything you
need to know.
Malekith
Dark Elf Malekith had virtually no personality,
and basically existed as a freaky-looking
dude trying to get an Infinity Stone, and
Thanos already does that way, way better.
It's a shame, because on the surface, Malekith
is extremely formidable.
He even stages a surprise assault on Asgard
itself, breaching the city's defenses, and
later sets his sights on Earth.
He put up a heck of a fight against Thor in
the final act of The Dark World, though the
God of Thunder still prevails.
Taserface
As Rocket points out more than a few times,
Taserface's name is pretty dumb, but he still
has enough wits to lead a mutiny among Yondu's
crew of Ravagers.
He's big, mean, ruthless, and conniving, and
brokers an uneasy alliance with Nebula to
take Yondu's ship in Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol. 2.
He isn't all that bright, but hey, those other
four traits go a long way, for awhile, anyway.
Whiplash
Mickey Rourke's Whiplash was one of many problems
in Iron Man 2, despite some admittedly awesome
action scenes along the way.
Whiplash never feels all that intimidating,
at least after that epic attack at the Monaco
Grand Prix.
He's motivated by a vague, kinda boring backstory,
and teams up with Justin Hammer, who, we've
already established, kinda sucks.
And then there was that odd obsession with
his bird...
Raza
When Obadiah Stane decides to take out Tony
Stark while Stark's on an overseas tour in
the first Iron Man film, he contacts the terrorist
organization the Ten Rings, led by Raza, to
make it happen.
Raza keeps Stark captive and proves an intimidating
villain, at least until Stark builds his first
version of the Iron Man suit and makes short
work of Raza's soldiers.
Raza was savvy enough to survive, and he tracked
down stray bits of Stark's armor and tried
to cut another deal with Stane.
The problem?
Stane was more savvy than Raza, and used a
sonic taser to paralyze him and kill his men.
Despite his unceremonious ending, Raza is
still technically the first villain we met
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe, and a throwback
to the simple days of the MCU.
Korath the Pursuer
Korath has a small but memorable role in Guardians
of the Galaxy, which provided one of the most
memorable moments from the movie's opening
scenes.
"Hey, there's another name you might know
be by…"
"Star-Lord?"
"Who?"
"I'm Star-Lord, man…"
Though Star-Lord gets the better of him in
the end, Korath still puts up a heck of a
fight.
He also manages to reacquire the Infinity
Stone along with Nebula, which sets up Ronan
the Accuser's near-world-ending attack on
Xandar.
Without Korath, Ronan would've never had the
Infinity Stone to begin with, so he certainly
served a purpose.
He even holds his own against Drax the Destroyer
for awhile, at least until Drax rips out the
cybernetic implant in his head, killing him.
Hey, at least he went out fighting.
Ulysses Klaue
Andy Serkis actually does an extremely entertaining
job with Ulysses Klaue in both Age of Ultron
as well as Black Panther, which gives us a
believable version of the Klaw we know from
the comics - a character who still has the
potential to come back after his "death" as
a dude made of hot-pink sound waves.
Hopefully the MCU will resurrect this classic
comics B-lister for future supervillainous
action.
Sonny Burch
Walton Goggins is a genuine delight every
time he shows up on screen, and his appearance
in Ant-Man and the Wasp is no exception.
Sure, he doesn't do much compared to the likes
of Killmonger or Thanos, but he might be one
of the MCU's most "comic booky" villains ever.
As a dealer in illicit technology, Sonny Burch
is a character that, like the Vulture before
him, operates on the fringes of a universe
filled with magic hammers and alien technology.
The difference is Burch is the kind of sleazy
mastermind who rolls around in a white-and-gold
SUV, conducts his illegal business in broad
daylight, and commands an army of nameless,
motorcycle-riding henchmen.
He's like a 1960s Batman villain, transplanted
directly into the MCU.
Burch is the perfect character to have around
to reinforce the idea that there's more to
this world than Shakespearean gods and magic
space rocks.
The Tinkerer
The Tinkerer is exactly the kind of character
that the MCU needed, for the same reason that
he was exactly the kind of character that
the comics needed - someone who builds all
the gadgets the bad guys use to fight the
good guys.
He's certainly not the focus of Spider-Man:
Homecoming, but Phineas Mason is the kind
of bad guy who makes the MCU feel just a bit
more real.
The Prowler
Of all the impressive things about Spider-Man:
Homecoming, one of the most notable is just
how many characters the film pulled in from
the comics.
And the best minor villain appearance by far
is absolutely Aaron Davis, known in the comics
as the Prowler.
In the film, he's played by Donald Glover,
who acts as the thoroughly unimpressed straight
man to Peter Parker's "enhanced interrogation."
"What happened to your voice?"
"What do you mean what happened to my voice?"
"I heard you by the bridge, I know what a
girl sounds like."
"I'm not a girl, I'm a boy, I mean I'm a man."
It's one of the best comedic scenes in the
entire MCU, but what really makes it special
is Davis's mention of his nephew.
As comics readers know, Davis's nephew is
Miles Morales, who eventually takes the name
of Spider-Man.
As far as villainy goes, Davis doesn't accomplish
much beyond a failed arms deal.
Hinting at a future of the MCU that includes
Miles, though?
That's awesome.
Ayesha
She might not have been the big bad in Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol. 2, but the golden goddess
Ayesha was able to cause more than enough
trouble for Star-Lord and his team.
The leader of the powerful Sovereign, she
commands a fleet of remote-controlled warships
that come within one shot of taking out the
Milano following an extensive chase.
Moreover, the post-credit scene revealed Ayesha
seems to be responsible for creating Adam
Warlock, a major player in Marvel's cosmic
universe and someone we expect to meet in
Guardians of the Galaxy Volume 3.
If nothing else, that makes her more than
worthy of a slot on this list.
The Chitauri
These invading creeps basically served as
cannon fodder against Earth's Mightiest Heroes
in the final hour of The Avengers.
Even still, they are a massive alien army,
led by those positively terrifying gigantic
dragon-like ships that tore through Manhattan.
Their eventual humiliation notwithstanding,
the Chitauri were more than formidable enough
to push the Avengers to the brink in their
first big screen team-up.
Arnim Zola
In Captain America: The First Avenger, Arnim
Zola's appearance is basically just an Easter
egg.
In Winter Soldier, however, the setup of having
Zola around for the first movie pays off in
a cool way.
He might not be a robot with a camera for
a head and his face on a giant TV screen built
into his tummy like in the comics, but what
Winter Soldier's big reveal lacks in robot
bodies, it more than makes up for by making
him genuinely creepy.
The Black Order
The Black Order are perfectly serviceable
henchmen for Infinity War.
They manage to hit that sweet spot of being
threatening enough to present the heroes with
a challenge.
But they also provide additional room for
the action so that it's not just 40 people
trying to punch Thanos at the same time.
Ultimately, they're not so threatening that
they overshadow the actual villain of the
piece.
Each of them is distinct and visually menacing,
especially Ebony Maw.
Unfortunately, most of them don't actually
get to do much other than lose, so that's
a bit of a drawback.
Ronan the Accuser
In Guardians of the Galaxy, Ronan was a religious
zealot who co-opted the Power Stone to continue
his crusade to wipe out Xandar.
But even without one of those awesomely powerful
baubles, he's still a heck of a warrior.
After all, he laid waste to Drax the Destroyer
without even breaking a sweat.
He also had the guts to stick it to Thanos,
and actually walked away from the Mad Titan
without much consequence.
The Guardians were no match for Ronan individually,
but luckily, Star-Lord was able to actually
control the Infinity Stone with the help of
his team, his half-Celestial powers, and those
sweet dance moves, and they used its immense
power to blast the bad guy into oblivion.
Yellowjacket
Ant-Man's Darren Cross spent his entire career
trying to duplicate Hank Pym's shrinking formula.
But when he did it and created the Yellowjacket
combat suit, he didn't realize his copycat
formula was actually messing with his brain
chemistry, making him dangerously unstable.
That led to a villain who was not only dangerously
unhinged, but got some really cool fight scenes,
the best of which was on a child's play table.
Ghost
Ant-Man and the Wasp's super-powered villain
has a lot going for her.
Visually, her flickering and phasing through
objects is some of the coolest-looking stuff
we've seen in the MCU.
It's even better in the fight scenes, the
shrinking and growing stuff is fun, but pitting
that stuff against a completely different
set of powers makes for some pretty compelling
action.
Since she seemingly reforms at the end of
the film, we're obviously meant to like her.
She has a sympathetic backstory and motivation
as a victim of Hank Pym's egotistical past.
At the same time, we're also supposed to like
Hank, so his part in Ghost's backstory still
involves him ultimately being right.
None of this is too surprising.
Marvel is full of bad guys doing the wrong
thing for the right reasons, and vice versa,
but it does feel pretty clear that Ghost was
shoehorned into Ant-man & the Wasp, rather
than building her more organically.
Still, the effects are great, and Hannah John-Kamen's
performance captures Ava's understandable
bitterness and desperation effectively.
Surtur
Diehard comics fans know Surtur is a major
villain in Thor's world.
In Thor: Ragnarok, however, he's almost an
ancillary one, appearing only in the opening
act and destructive finale.
That's not to say he's not important to the
story.
In Norse mythology, the word "Ragnarok" points
to the apocalyptic battle between gods that
results in a world destroyed by fire.
While Surtur is indeed the monster all Asgardians
fear, Thor and Loki summon him to invoke the
Ragnarok prophecy.
This defeats Hela, but at a price: his attack
decimates Asgard, crumbling the city in the
sky to dust.
The Mandarin
Ben Kingsley's character in Iron Man 3 wasn't
actually the real Mandarin, and the "All Hail
the King" one-shot short suggested the bona
fide bad guy could still be out there, waiting
to make his move.
But that "fake" Mandarin still gave us the
chills, at least until it was revealed that
he's really just an out of work actor named
Trevor Slattery who can barely be trusted
with a six-pack of beer, much less a gun.
Still, though it loses some luster by the
end, the Mandarin presented in the front half
of Iron Man 3 is one of the scariest baddies
in the MCU.
It might've been a ruse, but it was effective.
"And you'll never see me coming."
Red Skull
There was every chance it would come off as
silly, but Red Skull easily stands out as
one of the most original and terrifying baddies
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
In The First Avenger, he commands his own
HYDRA-branded Nazi division, complete with
Tesseract-powered weapons, and has his own
version of the Super Soldier Serum, making
him Cap's physical equal.
He vanished while trying to harness the power
of the Tesseract's Space Stone, but his surprise
return as the guardian of the Soul Stone in
Infinity War only served to remind us how
great he was so many years ago.
Kaecilius
He might've just been a disciple of Dormammu,
but Kaecilius was plenty intimidating his
own right, a highly-trained sorcerer who went
rogue, left the Ancient One's order to try
and take out the Masters of the Mystic Arts,
and nearly succeeded.
In Doctor Strange, Kaecilius manages to destroy
two Sanctums, put the Ancient One's forces
on the ropes, and shows his prowess with magic
in a few excellent fights against Doctor Strange.
Luckily, a quick-thinking Strange managed
to turn the tables and win the day.
Even if he was technically the B-list baddie
in Doctor Strange, he'll always be an A-lister
to us.
Crossbones
Brock Rumlow started out as a member of Captain
America's strike team in Winter Soldier, eventually
revealing himself as a HYDRA agent when the
attempted takeover began.
He managed to survive, and resurfaced during
the opening fight in Civil War, where he went
toe-to-toe with both Cap and Black Widow before
blowing himself up in the event that ended
up driving the Avengers apart.
For a villain, that's a pretty good way to
go out.
Dormammu
He's one of the biggest villains in Marvel
Comics, and the MCU actually kept the extremely
powerful ruler of the Dark Dimension relatively
close to his comics counterpart.
Doctor Strange's trip to the Dark Dimension
was practically a Steve Ditko panel brought
to life.
Dormammu is so powerful that Doctor Strange
had no chance of hurting him...and had to
outsmart him to save the world.
He trapped the villain in a time loop where
Dormammu killed him over and over, until he
was forced to bargain for his freedom.
It makes for one of the most clever finales
in all of the MCU, and lands Dormammu high
on our list of favorites.
Alexander Pierce
When Marvel signed Robert Redford for a superhero
movie, you knew it'd be an interesting role,
and his turn as Alexander Pierce delivered.
He's introduced as the well-meaning Secretary
of the World Security Council and old friend
of Nick Fury…though it's eventually revealed
Pierce is actually a HYDRA agent leading their
infiltration of S.H.I.E.L.D.
Pierce shepherded the program designed to
create the networked helicarrier system everyone
is fighting over in The Winter Soldier.
He also planted bombs in the name tags of
the other Security Council members, which
he uses to brutally murder them when they
challenge his takeover.
He stayed evil to the end, too, uttering "hail
Hydra" with his dying breath after Nick Fury
put two rounds into his chest.
Now that's a villain.
"Hail Hydra."
Aldrich Killian
Iron Man 3 is one of the most polarizing movies
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe, featuring
an epic fakeout that reveals Guy Pearce's
Aldrich Killian is actually the villain behind
a mysterious rash of bombings and terrorist
attacks sweeping the globe.
His secret weapon?
Extremis, a versatile technology that first
showed up in the Iron Man comics and is reimagined
here as a way to super-heat one's body and
literally regrow limbs.
Killian's particular skill-set makes for one
of the most technically ambitious fight scenes
in the MCU.
It's sometimes hard to believe any villain
can truly go toe-to-toe with Tony Stark, but
Killian made a heck of a run.
The Grandmaster
When Thor is suddenly marooned on the junk
planet Sakaar, he comes in contact with the
Grandmaster.
In the comics, the Grandmaster is just an
immortal dude who loves playing games of any
kind.
But in the hands of Jeff Goldblum, the Grandmaster
becomes one of the weirdest and funniest characters
in the MCU.
Here's hoping we get to see a lot more of
him in the future - though maybe not as much
as he wants us to.
"On any other world I'd be like millions of
years old, but here on Sakaar…"
Iron Monger
You have to respect where it all began, and
Jeff Bridges' Obadiah Stane, a.k.a. Iron Monger,
set the tone for the villains of the MCU in
the first Iron Man film.
Bridges' Stane is positively slimy, betraying
Tony Stark and actually setting his entire
hero's journey in action, so really, we can
thank Stane for kicking off the entire Marvel
Cinematic Universe.
When his assassination attempt on Stark in
the desert failed, Stane eventually donned
the massive Iron Monger suit to try and finish
the job himself.
A lot has changed since Iron Monger stalked
the skies, but his final fight with Iron Man
had a brutal, messy feel that really let you
feel the hate Stane had for Stark, and it
still resonates, even in a world with heavy
hitters like Thanos prowling around.
Ultron
James Spader brought absolute terror to the
metal menace that was Ultron, with a near-endless
supply of robot baddies and a design that
had comics fans geeking out.
He exemplifies how technology can be our greatest
scourge, though Ultron does it with a wit
that only Spader can provide, verbally sparring
with the best of them.
Like any great villain, Ultron also has a
real motivation for his dastardly deeds.
Looking at the facts, Ultron's final determination
that humans and superheroes are what make
the world such a dangerous place makes its
own twisted kind of sense.
Helmut Zemo
The most amazing thing about Helmut Zemo in
Civil War is he's just an average guy.
No plans for world domination.
Just a man who wants revenge for the death
of his family, and wise enough to realize
the best way to take out the Avengers is to
set them against one another.
Yes, his plan does require a few big leaps
of movie logic, but it was refreshing to see
a villain like Zemo brought to life in the
MCU.
He's a great reminder that it doesn't take
world-smashing superpowers to give Earth's
Mightiest Heroes a run for their money.
Ego
Peter Quill's search for his father was a
key part of Guardians of the Galaxy Volume
2, a journey that brought him face to face
with Kurt Russell's Ego, who's as bad a dad
as they come.
"Yes Drax, I've got a Snake Plissken."
"Hah!
Thank you!"
Ego is one of the most powerful villains in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe, right up there
alongside Thanos himself.
Ego's essentially a god who wants to literally
become the universe by supplanting all other
life.
And Russell sells it so well that you really
understand where Ego's coming from, even if
he's a psychopath who's killed hundreds of
his own children in his quest for power.
Ego redefined the concept of daddy issues.
"Of course I have issues!
That's my freakin' father!"
The Vulture
In a universe of world-destroying monsters,
the Vulture is decidedly street-level in his
approach, but that's exactly what makes him
work.
The writers tweaked his backstory to make
Adrian Toomes the father of Peter Parker's
teenage crush in Spider-Man: Homecoming, and
he takes the "girlfriend's angry dad" trope
to a whole new level.
The effects team also did an amazing job with
his armor and look, with the Vulture looking
positively terrifying and inhuman when he's
stalking his prey.
Hela
We've never seen Thor face a villain like
Hela, the Goddess of Death in any of the other
MCU films.
Much like Loki before her, this Asgardian
villain is someone audiences will immediately
love to hate.
As soon as Odin passes away, Hela appears
to the brothers and presents her plan to take
her rightful place on Asgard's throne.
To prove her point, she easily crushes Thor's
hammer.
The truth is eventually revealed that Hela
once acted as Odin's executioner, leading
the Asgardian army to victory over all Nine
Realms.
This secret history elevates Hela to epic
villain status.
Erik Killmonger
Erik Killmonger essentially has a superhero's
origin: his father is killed in front of him,
his royal heritage is denied to him, and he
uses those tragedies to motivate a relentless
dedication, training himself to the peak of
his abilities before seeking vengeance.
That setup is a whole lot closer to Batman
than it is to, say, Crossbones or Ultron.
When you add in the fact that Killmonger specifically
wants to address a continuing history of racism,
it's hard not to admit that he makes some
pretty good points.
Even if he's right, though, his goal is dominance
rather than leadership, which makes him a
true ideological opponent for T'Challa.
It's one of the things that makes their final
battle, in which they're both in nearly identical
Black Panther costumes, so good: they're reflections
of each other, both committed to fight for
their ideals without compromising who they
are.
Loki
While we originally said that villains turned
good guys weren't going to be on the list,
we had to make an exception for the god of
mischief, especially since Loki was a baddie
for multiple Marvel movies and caused so much
chaos throughout the MCU.
There's a reason Marvel Studios chose to use
Loki as the main villain for The Avengers,
he's one of the most compelling, calculated
and charismatic villains ever.
Tom Hiddleston is so good at being bad that
Marvel opted to keep him around long after
his bid for supremacy was foiled at the hands
of Earth's Mightiest Heroes.
He's still no match for the Hulk…
"Puny god…"
...but who is?
Oh, wait, we know who…
Thanos
Thanos is the villain of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe.
There's been a lot of character work put into
the cinematic version of Thanos, which is
especially impressive considering that most
of it is shown to the audience in Infinity
War, a movie that's also juggling story arcs
for dozens of other characters at the same
time.
Through it all, he's shown to have the same
quality that all the greatest villains share:
he thinks he's right.
He's the hero of his own story, the only one
who can step up and save the universe from
itself, and is willing to sacrifice whatever
he needs to in pursuit of that goal.
In the comics, Thanos has been referred to
as "the ultimate nihilist," but the MCU's
version is the exact opposite.
He believes very much in what he's doing,
which makes him even more compelling… and
more dangerous.